[Musique]
il a goûté cette année par nos
enquêteurs n'avaient plus le feu sacré
loin de là sébastien demorand travaille
alors pour le gault et millau donne le
sentiment de l'à peu près du le
prestigieux guide a fait tomber le
couperet deux places seulement où l'on
retrouvait le grand passard le passage
simple presque indolent tout le reste
n'était que décevant très décevant
service mécanique froidement
professionnels kompass et une atmosphère
de brasserie de luxe dans une salle où
tout naguère fut subtil les clients que
nous sommes ont eu l'impression d'être
pris pour des gogos vous y alliez fort
ouais on avait beaucoup de on était
terriblement déçu le guide est déçu
la note de l'établissement passe de 19 à
18 bien sûr ça reste une bonne note bien
sûr ça reste une note extraordinaire
évidemment mais s'il voulait
symboliquement il n'y a plus marqué 18
y'a plus qu'à plus marqué 19 il ya une
petite flèche vers le bas qui signifie
que l'établissement est en baisse c'est
un établissement qui était à 19 sur 20
depuis 1991
dis donc dix ans après avoir porté au
pinacle alain passard gaulle mieux se
permet de dire attention cette maison
vieillit mal moi je me souviens un jour
de une botte d'aspergés e énorme des
très très belle asperges comme ça d'un
diamètre mais extraordinaire elle était
ficelé en bottes comme ça et puis il a
émis deux dans des quartiers de citron
vert des bâtonnets de citronnelle choses
comme ça et les asperges il les cuisait
dans un sautoir verticale avec un fonds
de bear comme ça et elle était
simplement arrosée au beurre pendant des
heures qu'est ce que vous avez à
l'arrivée vous avez un pied qui est
quasiment cramer noir confie avec de
l'amertume
vous avez un coeur qui est moelleux et
vous avez une tête qui est presque cru
avec des sensations de verdeur inouïe
quoi et en un plat vous avez trois
moments trois émotions
et ça c'est plafond
[Musique]